des sites industriels et ferroviaires
des sites de construction et un quartier
résidentiel tout cela se côtoient dans
point de Saint-Charles et il y a un
nouveau venu
le renne et ces quelques 600 passages
prévus chaque jour de quoi pousser un
résident à mesurer le bruit produit sous
ses fenêtres
pour recueillir nos propres données nous
avons un sonomètre professionnel nous
sommes à environ 300 mètres des rails du
REM dans le quartier point de
Saint-Charles nous allons le placer pour
évaluer le climat sonore
il y aura des pointes autour de 75
décibels lors de notre passage des
chiffres préoccupants selon la santé
publique de Montréal 50 55 décibels
moyennés sur une journée pour une
période pour pour une longue période
alors des années il y a des attaques sur
le sommeil c'est sûr le dérangement le
stress tous les impacts sur les qualités
de vie et à long terme sur les maladies
cardiovasculaires aux abords de
griefington des murs anti-bruits ont été
installés mais rien autour de points de
Saint-Charles où le REM circule à
environ 20 mètres de hauteur
comme un peu si on entendait une navette
spatiale si ça fait comme
il y en a beaucoup qui sont incommoder
il y en a que ça les empêche de dormir
mais le bruit varie beaucoup selon
l'endroit et selon le seuil de tolérance
personnelle même avec l'extérieur
j'interesse sur le toit j'ai un cours et
c'est pas un commandant du tout après
avoir répondu aux résidents que le bruit
du renne n'était pas significatif c'est
des PQ infras finalement décidé de
prendre de nouvelles mesures cette
modélisation est présentement en cours
nous écrit la caisse et nous rendrons
les rapports disponibles lorsqu'ils
seront complétés Valérie plante attend
le REM et ses rapports avec la même
impatience de très très près voir ce que
les sonomètres relèvent comme bruit et
on va agir en conséquence et c'est ton
premier lieu à l'exploitant de réduire
la source du bruit selon ce spécialiste
je pense que c'est important de voir
d'abord ce qu'on peut faire du côté
infrastructure et vraiment REM LEM doit
entrer en service au début de cet été
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal